a volte nella vita tutto va bene e
quando tutto va bene neanche te ne rendi
conto
poi improvvisamente accadono degli
eventi decisivi delle rotture ci
ritroviamo così a raccogliere i pezzi a
metterli insieme a cercare di riunirli
incollarli sta proprio a noi scegliere
come vogliamo rimetterli insieme
ti ricordi come sei fatto quella
cicatrice sul sopracciglio quella sul
ginocchio sullo stinco
ti ricordi come dove eri quando è
successo
ogni cicatrice a una data un luogo una
storia
a me piace fare liste mi piace
catalogare mappare e una volta ho
pensato perché non lo faccio dello
stesso corpo perciò ho realizzato la
mappatura delle cicatrici
sì devo dire che sono o una
costellazione di pallini rossi che mi
appartengono
queste realtà è dovuto al fatto che ho
una rara sindrome se si chiama ehlers
danlos è una collagenopatie una malattia
rara nel tessuto connettivo
in sintesi la pelle è come seta e liscia
e vellutata
wow troppo e così fragile che appena
batte si apre si ferisce facilmente e si
cicatrizza con difficoltà una volta un
medico mi ha detto che solo per stare in
piedi
e come se spingessi un muro tutto il
giorno quando quando sei bambino
normalmente scopri il mondo
cadendo rialzando ti cadendo rialzando
ti scopri il mondo scoprendolo grazie al
tuo corpo
io non potevo cadere perché sennò finivo
subito in ospedale
perciò a di areazione i bambini
correvano in cortile e io rimanevo in
classe a coronare quadretti e mi piaceva
tantissimo
perciò ok gli altri potevano correre
però io potevo fare altro io potevo
colorare e disegnare potevo volare con
la fantasia volare ho preso tre volte
l'elicottero della croce rossa ho preso
due volte la motoslitta sempre e ho
scoperto tutti i suoni dell'ambulanza
cioè esperienze che una persona normale
non vivrebbe ma poi che cos'è questa
normalità
chi è normale la normalità lo agognata
nell'adolescenza perché un adolescente
vuole essere come gli altri
e invece ero diversa visibilmente
diversa aero fragile mingherlina e e
allora mettevo gonne lunghe per
nascondere le cicatrici sulle gambe
anche d'estate mettevo magliette larghe
per nascondere il busto ortopedico e
avevo calcolato una distanza una
prossemica dalle persone che facesse sì
che nessuno si potesse avvicinare a un
metro di distanza da me ai tempi nostri
si potrebbe dire che sono stata una
delle pioniere degli attuali dpcm ok se
qualcuno si avvicinava a me sai con
quell'aria un po curiosa un po schifata
guardava le cicatrici e diceva poverina
ma che hai fatto
poverina inventavo storie è nata la mia
risposta che io gli inventari favole gli
raccontavo di draghi principesse
ovviamente io e la mia storia preferita
che raccontava di una damigella così
fragile che era stata messa in un enorme
bolla di cristallo ed è lì che va
vissuto quasi tutta la sua vita
poi un giorno si era innamorata saranno
morata di un bellissimo trombettista con
i baffi e così ha scelto di appartenere
a questo mondo ha scelto di uscire dalla
bolla da quella protezione
sapeva che sarebbe stato pericoloso per
il suo corpo ma avrebbe potuto vivere
gioie e dolori a pieno e ne vale la pena
e così che ho capito che siete in realtà
piace piace occhi negli occhi non piaci
stinchi negli stinchi ho capito che
potevo di indossarli con disinvoltura
mettere una gonna lunga per il piacere
di farlo non per nascondere qualcosa
in fin dei conti
c'è chi si fa i tatuaggi per imprimere
un identità sul corpo io costellazioni
di avventure io ho date luoghi
elicotteri chomon di tutti iscritti sul
mio corpo
io ho iscritta sul mio corpo la mia
storia le cicatrici possono essere anche
invisibili invisibili
vuol dire che non puoi capirle perché
non le vedi invisibile può essere un
trauma un lutto una malattia invisibile
il dolore è invisibile il dolore non
l'altro non sa che dolore tu provi le
breton dice ognuno è solo nel proprio
dolore è vero come fai a comunicare
perciò per tentare di comunicare
l'incomunicabile ti aggrappi alle
metafore l'arte non è proprio la
metafora della vita
il lavoro dell'artista non è quello di
sensibilizzare di spiegare più
facilmente far fluire un'informazione
che magari non sarebbe facile da
assorbire raggiungere spiegare delle
cose attraverso la propria sensibilità
è così che io e mia sorella ilaria che
fotografa siamo molto unite abbiamo
scelto una volta di fare un progetto
fotografico si chiama fragile
abbiamo voluto raccontare sì una
malattia rara ma attraverso uno sguardo
complice di due sorelle abbiamo voluto
a raccontarlo con poesia le malattie
rare sono più di 6mila se io ti racconto
una storia emoziona magari tela
ricorderai ecco questo era il nostro
desiderio per me è stato molto difficile
perché mi sono mostrata io ero abituata
veramente a nascondermi e con un
progetto del genere mi sono messa a nudo
nel vero senso della parola è stato
difficilissimo e non male ho capito di
fregarmene di più è anche un sacco di
gente ha cominciato a scrivermi
iscriverci perché aveva bisogno della
dello stesso feedback
ci ho preso gusto ho scritto un libro
una biografia
quando l'ho scritta è stato come tirare
le reti cioè come se quando tu vivi il
tuo presente è un'accozzaglia indistinta
di eventi ordinari e straordinari quando
tele riguardi da un altro punto di vista
è come se fai ordine come se una cosa
porta anche all'altra come se spesso gli
eventi anche quelli più difficili
dolorosi traumatici ti fanno arrivare a
una maggiore consapevolezza a volte
anche un piccolo errore quotidiano ti
può far capire delle cose
una volta ero in casa con mia sorella
stavano sistemando l'entrata c'è la
testa di buddha una cesta pienissima di
chiavi e una composizione giapponese che
è stata regalata a me e mio marito per
il nostro matrimonio
mio marito è sempre quello con i baffi
il trombettista la ci sono lo sposo e la
sposa in ceramica inavvertitamente mia
sorella sfiora la sposina ma proprio a
sposina non el eccola che cade in mille
pezzi
lei sapeva quanto fosse importante per
me perché ho cominciato a blaterare
tela ricompro con vado in giappone
chiamo il giappone compro il già le è
venuto in mente che va letto da poco un
articolo che parlava di king sughi corre
in camera torna subito col suo articolo
e legge in oro sughi riparare è
un'antica arte giapponese in cui le
porcellane rotte vengono riparate con
loro proprio per renderle ancora più
preziose nelle loro crepe dorate e
l'arte di abbracciare il danno di
rendere preziose e accettare le proprie
cicatrici per valorizzarle perché esse
stesse sono parte della tua storia
dettori la ma il perfetto ripariamo la
così e così l'abbiamo riparata e quando
io l'ho tenuto in mano con questa
porcellana quando 36 crepe dorate ho
capito che ora si che mi assomigliava
ora era come me io sono una porcellana
keane sughi in cui ho iscritta sul mio
cortona storia è nata una performance
io mi ero in cui ripercorre le mie
cicatrici proprio con loro per
valorizzarle
oggi siamo chiamati tutti a ripararci
sia mentalmente che fisicamente
oggi abbiamo avuto una rottura a causa
della pandemia
quello che io ho imparato dalle
esperienze che spesso dalle rotture più
difficili
capiamo quali sono i nostri veri valori
cioè cosa veramente vogliamo cosa è
prezioso per noi cosa vogliamo essere
cosa vogliamo fare
io ad esempio sono dopo il primo log da
hong son tornato a vivere a firenze in
campagna qualità della vita assoluta
ora io vorrei farvi è proprio un gesto
simbolico questo
è un è una foglia d'oro che io uso nella
mia performance
io vi propongo di chiudere gli occhi
immaginare di prenderla di metterla dove
più ne sentite bisogno perché ognuno di
noi è unico e prezioso grazie
[Applauso]